ça fait un moment qu'on en parle du
samsung galaxy à 7 ça fait un moment où
j'avais dit que alors enfin vous sortir
ma vidéo test et pas comme ça y est le
grand jour est arrivé
je les tester les tester de tous les
côtés sur la plus secouée ces couleurs
plein de trucs vraiment sympa il ya des
choses qui m'ont vraiment plu dans ce
téléphone il ya deux pointes qui m'ont
quand même vachement moins enthousiasmé
bon le mieux c'est de vous expliquer ça
directement
[Musique]
pour moi le galaxy a fait de 2018 2018
ces trois promesses essentiel est la
toute première c'est d'avoir un écran de
très grande qualité
la deuxième c'est d'avoir de l'audio
très grande qualité au casque avec du
dolby et moss et la troisième se la voir
d'excellentes photos avec un triple
capteurs situés c'est l'arrière ça c'est
un peu une première chez samsung
alors on va les tailles et tous les
points ensemble voir ce qui est bien pas
bien voilà on va commencer déjà par la
base de la base la base de la base de la
base de la base c'est ce qui est sûr
maîtriser par samsung
c'est son écran 6 pouces super amoled
résolution de 1200 pixels par 1080
pixels séduit fhd plus à 411 ppp ça
marche extrêmement bien là je n'ai pas
poussé à fond je pousse la luminosité à
fond alors le but attention c'est pas de
me flinguer les yeux mais ça marche
vraiment très très bien
l'écran d'une excellente qualité samsung
sur maîtrise son sujet au niveau des
dalles
d'un point de vue purement fichage
comment plaisir de lecture plaisir pour
regarder des vidéos
c'est un vrai régal pour regarder des
vidéos sur youtube
c'est vraiment super hop vous venez
zoomer ça vous fait un plus grand écran
la qualité est vraiment bien c'est
vraiment hyper hyper hyper cool ça c'est
un emploi qui est très vite résolu
l'affichage chez samsung c'est sûr
maîtriser ça marche très bien puisque
dans le multimédia on va y rester
du point de vue de l'audio on a un haut
parleur mono qui se situe là qui envoie
franchement suffisamment sont alors le
fonds est assez l'hélium bon on est sur
un smartphone haut de gamme
là dessus on va pas trop lui en vouloir
ça fonctionne et de la puissance
ça va ça marche mais là où ça devient
vraiment vraiment cool c'est lorsque
vous allez venir brancher un casque
tout simplement parce que vous allez
pouvoir utiliser le dolby atmos dans vos
paramètres il faut vous alliez dans son
vous allez tout en bas vous allez dans
qualité et effets sonores et là vous
avez activé le dolby atmos mais juste
avant il faut vous puissiez hop vous
branchez votre casque vous allez pouvoir
activer le dolby et moss et là vous
allez vraiment arriver dans une autre
dimension alors vous avez plusieurs
prêts sept films musique voix laisser
leur automatique ça ira très très bien
et là aussi vous allez pouvoir régler
tous vos paramètres les paramètres
avancés vous allez pouvoir quel est
votre équaliseur en fonction de
fréquences
bon faut quand même s'y connaître un
petit peu pour pouvoir faire sinon vous
allez pouvoir régler ici plus de basses
plus des guides plus d'instruments plus
de voix en gros ça va vous changer les
fréquences tout simplement c'est un peu
la même chose que ça met en mode pour
les nuls
enfin il ya pas mal de petits réglages
mais vraiment l'expérience sonore n'est
pas du tout la même
c'est énorme et là encore je découpe du
mp3 si jamais je me mettais autre chose
que du mp3 on arrive dans vraiment autre
chose le fait de pouvoir contrôler ses
basses ses aigus choisir ses fréquences
avec ce dolby et moss c'est vraiment une
super expérience
maintenant il ya un autre mot que
j'adore et je trouve extrêmement bien
réussi dessus c'est la position du
capteur d'empreintes digitales
ici sur la tranche juste là là c'est
vraiment bien pensé vraiment bien
réfléchi d'un point de vue ergonomique
ça se prend très très facilement en main
vous poser à peine votre doigt dessus il
déverrouille tout de suite c'est
vraiment vraiment vraiment bien et en
plus on va beaucoup plus loin alors déjà
pour les droitiers c'est vraiment très
très facile pour les gauchers vous allez
venir appuyer directement ici avec votre
majeur les droitiers avec votre pouce ça
marche c'est rapide c'est pratique et ça
va surtout beaucoup plus vite que les
capteur d'empreinte digitale intégrée à
l'écran comme en trouve sur les
smartphones actuels haut de gamme
une petite astuce on peut l'utiliser en
glissant dessus pour ouvrir votre vol et
de raccourcis ça marche très bien
c'est pratique c'est cool alors
attention si vous laissez glisser votre
doigt dessus ça peut rapidement devenir
vous embêter mais dans l'absolu une fois
qu'on a pris le coup c'est franchement
génial ça pour venir activé il faut
aller dans vos paramètres fonctions
avancées et vous allez ensuite danger
capteur d'empreinte vous venez active
est là et ça marchera très très bien en
termes de performance trouve qui
fonctionne pas trop mal
vous avez l'exynos 7885 couplé à 4 gigas
de ram ça fonctionne bien c'est pas une
foudre de guerre mais pour utilisation
standard email sms multimédia jeux
franchement ça fera l affaire
autre point qui écoule d'un point de vue
logiciel c'est le game launcher cela
faisait retrouver tous vos jeux vidéo
avec pas mal de paramètres vous allez
avoir un menu dédié ici vous avez accès
à vos raccourcis pas dallaire quand je
pas de sms blocage pendant le jeu
renvoyez ça sert tout qui se développe
énormément et que je trouve toujours
très très très efficace on voit pour le
coup que samsung vraiment briguer un peu
les gamer les gamer qui sont ciblés par
des marques comme au nord dans le milieu
de gamme et notamment sur une cible
jeune qui aurait tendance à délaisser
samsung pour aller du côté de chez au
nord pourquoi je ne peux pas rentrer il
se passe des choses très bizarres dans
pib j'ai là donc je sais pas ce qui se
passe dans l'erreur de bugs
je ne peux pas entrer dans l'est dans
les immeubles pour m'équiper je ne peux
rien faire
voilà ça c'est très très bizarre en tout
cas bon en terme de fluidité je trouve
qu'ils fonctionnent bien là c'est le jeu
qui aveugle je sais pas pourquoi je veux
qu'ils aient passé mais sinon ça me
paraît si fluide or il ya quelques
moments où ça lag un peu on est on est
pas non plus sur un truc de dingue a
roulé sur un exocet 1885 c'est du milieu
de gamme
bon voilà ça fait là faire ça marche
mais pour quelques parties de gainey ça
ira très bien
qu'en est il maintenant l'autonomie et
ça c'est juste une question très drôle
parce qu'il faut savoir quand même que
là dessus on a une batterie de 3300
milliards eur alors sur le modèle de
l'an dernier on avait une batterie de
trois mille sept cent mille yop erreur
néanmoins je me sens pas les et là
dessus on tient une bonne journée alors
ça dépend toujours de votre utilisation
si vous jouez énormément si vous le
sollicitez beaucoup l'autonomie ça va
être moins ça par contre pour une
utilisation un peu standard des sms
quelques emails quelques photos un peu
de jeu mais pas trop vous le tenez une
journée sans aucun problème
après attention vous n'avez pas ici du
sb type c vous avez du micro usb et un
rechargement qui est assez long il vous
faut un peu plus de deux heures pour
recharger votre smartphone
bon voilà faut prévoir quand même le
court faut avoir un peu de temps devant
soi et pas forcément être trop pressés
soit maintenant m'attaquer la partie la
plus intéressante là dessus c'est la
partie photo vidéo notamment photo avec
le triple capteur arrière
si c'est pas que vous il ya parce que au
final lorsque j'ai vu arriver ce triple
capteur photo sur ce smartphone sur le
sm se dit cool
samsung va vraiment y aller fort en
offrant un smartphone avec une
excellente qualité photo et vidéo
samsung maîtrise vraiment son sujet en
termes de photos vidéos et je trouve que
là sur ce set
ils sont un peu en dessous c'est un peu
dommage dans plus qu'à la concurrence
dans cette gamme de prix et des modèles
qui sont quand même assez robuste de ce
point de vue là et je comprends pas je
comprends pas parce que samsung sans
maîtrise et écran mais aussi vraiment
bon au niveau de ces caméras et là je
sais pas ce qui s'est passé on a
l'impression qu'ils ont voulu faire une
démonstration de force et qu'au final
c'est pas tout à fait ça vous avez donc
ici trois capteurs photo un capteur
principal de 24 mégapixels avec
l'ouverture de f1 points 7 donc censé
être très bon en faible luminosité avec
notamment en autofocus à détection de
phase en deuxième de 5 mégapixels tu vas
surtout venir en renfort pour le mode
portrait ouverture de f 2.4 et en 3e
8 mégapixels ultra grand-angle de 120
degrés avec une ouverture de f 2.2 et là
qu'on s'attendrait à voir quelque chose
qui déchire vraiment en termes de photos
au final le rendu de ses moyens alors
oui et donc c'est à dire que si vous le
nourrissez avec beaucoup de lumière il
sera correct a pas trop lui en demander
on n'est pas dans la précision sur la
photo sur son smartphone mais le rendu
sera correct si maintenant il ya un peu
moins lumière on va perdre on va perdre
ça va être vraiment beaucoup moins
précis moins net mais c'est un petit peu
ce que je reprochais un smartphone en
termes de photos c'est à dire qu'il fait
des promesses on a de vraies attentes
avec un triple module photo et ses
moyens alors après il ya un effet quel
très sympa c'est l'effet avec l' ultra
grand-angle de 120 degrés je vous montre
un regard des quelques photos regarder
des photos prises normalement et ensuite
avec l' ultra grand-angle ça c'est
vraiment bien pour faire des photos de
groupe ça marche c'est agréable
c'est plutôt efficace mais c'est pareil
en termes de précision au niveau du
cliché on y perd un peu après le mode
portrait fonctionne pas mal le détourage
et franchement correct ça c'est quelque
chose qu'ils maîtrisaient aussi de la
part de samsung
les photos ans elle fit fonctionne pas
trop mal pour faible luminosité non plus
c'est pas trop ça on perd vraiment
précision il ya beaucoup de bruit ça
bouge c'est instable après là dessus on
est sur un smartphone milieu de gamme on
va pas lui demander d'être excellent
faible luminosité pour ça faut monter
sur le haut de gamme si vous avez tout
de suite ce galaxy s 9 voir notre 9 la
qualité photo est vraiment
impressionnante est excellente et là ça
marchera parfaitement bien mais par
contre ça plus du tout dans la même
gamme de tarifs ça c'est un smartphone
qui prix catalogue à 349 euros
on peut toucher un peu moins cher
d'ailleurs si vous intéresse vous avez
des liens en bas dans la description
pour aller jeter un petit coup d'oeil en
vidéo ça marche c'est pas non plus un
truc de dingue ça fonctionne 1080p bon
voilà ça c'est un truc assez standard ça
fonctionne plutôt pas mal en point
positif
l'écran
l'audio l'autonomie est correcte point
négatif il n'y a pas de certification
ip68 là dessus c'est un smartphone qui
n'est pas annoncée pour être étanche le
fait qu'audi du micro usb que la
recherche soit pas très rapide ça c'est
aussi un petit peu en plein de regrets
et puis la partie photo qui pour moi en
tout cas et pas à la hauteur des
promesses faites là dessus sur ce
smartphone en tout cas ce que je note
c'est ce qui est très positif c'est
qu'il ya une vraie volonté de la part de
samsung d'aller plus loin d'aller
chercher d'autres clients sur ce modèle
on est un peu dans l'antre 2 samsung a
plein de smartphones qui sont vraiment
d'excellente qualité il peut être fait
pour vous si la partie photo c'est pas
du tout du tout du tout une priorité
et si vous arrivez à le trouver un tarif
inférieur à 300 euros
là pour le coup il va devenir très
intéressant mais à 349 euros
je suis un peu partagé
dites moi ce que vous en pensez en bons
commentaires est ce que vous l'avez est
ce que vous pourriez l'avoir mais qu'est
ce que vous pensez de ce triple module
photo vous marquez tout ça on en discute
ensemble voilà soyez sages on va bientôt
checker le gisti ce qui est dans mes
placards on va bientôt leur garde et
l'ouvrir le tester je sais que vous
l'avez demandé d'excusés mais en ce
moment il ya beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de produits une très
grosse actu c'est un peu compliqué il
faudrait que pour que je sorte ou à
temps il faudrait deux vidéos jours je
fais mon accent peut-être que j'ai une
aprilia river 1 d'ici quelques temps en
attendant vous invite à rester connectés
des évidemment à checker mes playlists
pour voir quel smartphone est fait pour
vous il est aussi de la maison connectée
d'objets connectés pas mal de choses
même de la trottinette qui va arriver
voyez donc là c'est plutôt cool merci à
vous soyez sages et d'ici là
prenez soin de vous ciao